we start tonight with a fox news alert
ukraine facing an onslaught of heavy
artillery from invading russian troops
as putin's forces are closing in on the
country's two biggest cities this
morning in the city of kharkiv a
government building was rocked by an
explosion decimating the area and
reportedly killing at least six
on the capital of kiev the city's main
communication tower was pummeled by
rockets taking television and radio
stations temporarily off the air as
russia looks to destroy ukrainian
infrastructure and its ability to
broadcast
this all comes as a 40-mile long convoy
of russian tanks and artillery
accumulates just miles away from the
capitol looking to surround the city and
lay siege
the people of kiev are bracing for the
absolute worst as they gather supplies
and weapons to hold off the invaders
creating roadblocks in the streets and
removing street signs doing anything
they can to slow down
putin's barbaric assault
and they've already fought with honor
and courage holding off several key
russian advances neutralizing their
dominance in the sky with air defense
systems taking down fighter jets and
attack helicopters
but now russia is increasingly targeting
civilians seeking to make this conflict
as grim and as bloody as possible as
they attempt to destroy the morale of
the ukrainian people
secretary of state tony blinken called
out russia's atrocities this morning to
the un human rights council listen
russian strikes are hitting schools
hospitals
residential buildings civilian buses
cars even ambulances have been shelled
these are the human rights abuses this
council was created to stop
ukraine president zielinski called the
attacks on civilians in kharkiv this
morning a war crime
while nearly a hundred diplomats from
across the world walked out of a u.n
meeting when russia took the microphone
also today america caught russian spies
at the united nations conducting
espionage and we kicked them out of our
country
but while most of the world is standing
with ukraine russia still has some
friends out there new reports show that
putin is looking to create an
anti-fascist conference
the move would align russia with
pakistan china and saudi arabia among
other countries to create a legion of
doom
but as world allegiances start to shake
out it looks like things are only going
to get worse in ukraine
in the southeast part of the country
russia is attempting to create a land
bridge from the breakaway region all the
way to crimea
putin has deployed forces around the
port city of maripol an amphibious
assault taking place now if maripol
falls russian troops could then ferry
supplies into crimea and then link up
with the separatist forces there and
continue the assault from the south
directly connecting russia with crimea
and cutting off ukrainian supply lines
which be would be a deadly development
this is all part of putin's plan for a
three-pronged attack into the eastern
half of the country
with troops coming south from belarus
north from crimea and from the east and
kharkiv
they'll look to squeeze in on kiev
trying to choke the city and that is
when it gets really ugly
a senior u.s defense official has
confirmed that there is evidence of a
thermobaric weapon launcher inside
ukraine several of them
though they have not actually seen them
in use thermobaric bombs also known as
vacuum bombs or the father of all bombs
are more devastating than conventional
explosives they burn everybody and
everything in its blast radius
well their deployment in battle is not
exclusively outlawed by international
law any use of the bombs on civilian
areas
like what's being hinted at in kharkiv
is considered a war crime
this is the type of warfare that russia
is looking to inflict at this stage of
the war
this is going to be a long drawn-out
struggle as putin makes life as
miserable as possible for the ukrainian
people
but he's underestimating ukraine's
resistance these people will not flee or
surrender like you'd hoped
so when putin's brutality meets
ukrainian courage inside the capitol
what should we expect to see hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else